you can only imagine what must be going
through their minds
once they've crossed the border the
ukrainian refugees had quickly put on
buses and taken further into romania
we went with them
anya left home with her daughter but not
her husband he's stayed to fight
she's eight months pregnant so we'll
almost certainly give birth without him
and without any idea if she'll ever see
him again
she's broken
she left her husband behind
yes
where have they come from but they come
from kiev
she'd been able to speak to her husband
can she phone him
is he okay
he's fine
for now
we spent the day at the town football
stadium is now a temporary camp to
relieve pressure on the border they are
looked after well here there is genuine
tenderness for the arriving refugees
just a minute ago i talked with one girl
and she wants to go home that's it a
little girl a little girl just doesn't
go home nothing else
she doesn't care what happened wants to
go home
and this isn't home of course it's not
home whatever they go it's not home now
i mean it's going to stay with them for
for the rest of their lives yeah yeah
probably yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
arena was seven yesterday
she didn't have a party like all
seven-year-olds should
instead she fled the war
and so when she arrived in romania late
in the evening after a frightening day
the fire brigade did this for her
it was a basic act
of human kindness
there's been a lot of that here
but arena said she only wanted one
present
to be with her papa
she is another child without her dad
because he stayed behind to fight for
his country
aleister bunker sky news on the romanian
ukrainian border